welcome to the daily climate show coming
up today we'll be live in davos where
international leaders are grappling with
how to tackle climate change and the
global repercussions of the war in
ukraine
anthony albanese is sworn in as
australia's new prime minister with
action on climate change at top of the
agenda
and a senior safety consultant has
resigned from the energy giant shell
saying the company is causing extreme
harm to the planet
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show where we track the changes
happening to the world hear from the
people affected by those changes and
tried to get answers from those tasked
with tackling the problem
now alex sharma the president of the cop
26 climate summit has told sky news that
the crisis in ukraine will accelerate
the move away from dependence on fossil
fuels now climate is traditionally one
of the big issues that leaders try to
grapple with at the annual world
economic forum meeting in switzerland
but after russia's invasion of ukraine
the world's focus is elsewhere yet the
un has warned again and again this year
that we're not doing enough to avoid
catastrophic climate change well joining
me now from davos is our business
correspondent paul kelso and paul i know
you managed to grab a word with alok
sharma earlier he's determined isn't he
that climate change isn't sidelined at
this year's summit
yes he is he's actually probably the
ranking british politician in davos this
week there's no senior ministerial
presence no chance of the exchequer no
business secretary and as far as we know
no prime minister balak sharma is here
in his role as cop 26 president and
you're writing what you say in that
perhaps the headline attention has
shifted away from climate certainly in
the six months since glasgow and cop 26
yet about a third of the panels the
talking shops that go on here in this
rather rare refried conference
environment are about climate i suspect
that the agenda was put together before
the russian invasion of ukraine and the
consequences of that act of aggression
are that the immediate attention of
political leaders business leaders and
indeed civil society that's here is to
try and deal with uh the fallout from
what's happening just a couple of
thousand kilometers to the east but
speaking to alex sharma today he's here
trying to keep the renewable
flame to people's feet if you like to
try and keep up the pressure to get
people to deliver on the commitments
they made in glasgow and he told me that
he believes the war in ukraine will in
fact accelerate the shift to renewables
it's completely understandable that uh
as a result of russia's uh brutal and
illegal invasion of ukraine uh you are
seeing uh people focused uh on that
particular challenge uh that's
completely understandable of course we
have to stand shoulder to shoulder with
the people of ukraine but i think what
it is also done is highlighted the
vulnerability of countries relying on
fossil fuels particularly when they're
reliant on um hostile actors if i can
put it like that
and i think what you've seen in response
from countries around the world is a
realization that the way you ensure
energy security uh is to make sure that
you have homegrown clean energy you're
seeing that in the uk we've set out our
british energy security strategy very
clearly focused on renewables nuclear
clean energy you're seeing that coming
through from other countries as well
i've also spoken to the egyptian foreign
minister who's here because egypt
assumes the presidency of cop in
november and will host cop 27 in sharm
al-shaikh next year he
praised mr sharma's work he said they
were ready to take on the baton from the
uk and would continue the diplomatic
work it would be interesting to have an
african country hosting copy insisted it
wasn't an african cop but here you have
a a continent
that hasn't enjoyed the benefits of the
carbon age is feeling the impact of
climate change perhaps more immediately
than europe but clearly from what has
happened in ukraine despite all the
optimism from mr sharma and indeed the
egyptians real politic real events will
always potentially get in the way of
this long road and necessary road
driving business and governments towards
net zero
paul thanks very much indeed
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other climate news and australia
swore in a new prime minister today
after what was dubbed the climate
election labour leader anthony albanese
campaigned on stronger climate ambitions
than the outgoing pm scott morrison
pledging to cut emissions by 43 percent
by 2030 and reaching net zero by 2050.
an unprecedented number of independent
candidates were elected and they'll be
pivotal in holding the new government to
account on climate policy
in his victory speech this weekend
albanese pledged to end the climate wars
we can have an even better future
if we seize the opportunities that are
right there in front of us
the opportunity to shape change rather
than be shaped by it
and we can shape change more effectively
if we seek to unite people on that
journey of change
together we can end the climate wars
[Applause]
back in the uk the government has
launched a multi-billion pound scheme to
help reduce carbon emissions from
heating buildings homeowners can get
grants of up to five thousand pounds to
replace gas boilers with new low-carbon
heat pumps it's been met with criticism
however some experts say the fund is
only enough to help around 90 000 homes
across the country
a thick blanket of orange dust has
caused disruption across iraq the
sandstorm has led to extremely low
visibility and air quality effectively
closing down the capital baghdad and
forcing many people to hospital with
breathing difficulties
iraq is prone to seasonal sandstorms but
experts have warned their growing
frequency has been brought on by
desertification record low rainfall
and climate change
now a safety consultant who spent more
than a decade working as a contractor
for shell has publicly cut ties claiming
the oil and gas company is causing
extreme harm to the planet in an email
to hundreds of shell employees including
the chief executive
caroline dennett wrote that the company
is planning to expand oil and gas
exploration against the advice of united
nations climate scientists and she ended
her email
it pains me to end this working
relationship which i have greatly valued
and i can no longer work for a company
that ignores all the alarms and
dismisses the risks of climate change
and ecological collapse
well shell sent this statement in
response they said be in no doubt we are
determined to deliver on our global
strategy to be a net zero company by
2050 and thousands of our people are
working hard to achieve this we have set
targets for the short medium and long
term and have every intention of hitting
them we're already investing billions of
dollars in low-carbon energy although
the world will still need oil and gas
for decades to come in sectors that
can't be easily decarbonized
well i spoke to caroline dennett earlier
and asked her why she's cutting ties
with shell now
yeah i think it's because i really truly
believe that they're just ignoring the
risks of climate change and ecological
collapse um you know the alarm bells
have been ringing the united nations the
international energy agency all saying
that we must immediately cease with any
new oil and gas extractions and rapidly
transition to renewables for you know
for a safe uh future and a habitable
world and i just don't see that shadow
doing that in any meaningful way and
that really contradicts their
their ambition
for their safety ambitions which is
around do no harm but they are causing
harms on a massive scale because of
their uh disregard for the climate risks
and you know the ecological problems
that the oil and gas industry's uh
producing
you say they're ignoring the alarms
around climate change but they would
point out wouldn't they that they've got
a net zero target they aim to hit net
zero by 2050 they say they've also got
short medium and long term targets all
of which they intend to hit and they're
throwing billions into it
yeah they do say that but i i i
find it hard to believe that
if you are having that target that you
would still look for new uh oil and gas
licenses to take even more out of the
ground than what we have you know and
the science is absolutely clear we have
to leave it in the ground you know we
really cannot afford to increase global
heating any more than than it is going
to be already and if we continue to
extract more that's just going to put
more co2 into the atmosphere so i just
think there's a real contradiction in
what they say publicly and what they're
doing in reality well yes one of your
complaints has been hasn't it that you
say that shell isn't winding down its
oil and gas but they say believe they
believe that their oil production has
peaked they say they think it's been
going down since 2019.
yep that that may be the case for oil i
don't have though you know their
internal statistics on that but there is
certainly
um a race for more extraction projects
and for more licenses and i just would
have thought if you're serious about
transitioning that you would really stop
that you would create a new vision for
your company and lead us into that
future you know shell have been pioneers
in in the energy industry and i just
think it's a real shame that they're not
using all of their
their human and financial and technical
capital to uh
to to put us on the right path to a safe
future you know it just seems a shame
that they're really sticking their heels
in on this well yes i mean they say they
have plans to transition away from
fossil fuels to towards clean energy but
in the meantime
there the world does still need some oil
and gas because there are some sectors
that can't be easily decarbonized i mean
they've got a point there haven't they
yeah and i don't think anyone is saying
we need to turn the tap off right at
this moment we would obviously see
massive societal collapse if we if we
did that but i do think you know we need
to see evidence of that rapid transition
and on a scale uh that that is going to
save us and i just think they are a
company that has scale they are capable
of doing that they just need to um get
on with it but that i don't think they
are you know i think they're they're
still talking as if we have decades and
decades uh before we need to act you
know their 2050 target means that they
have to act now not wait until it's 20
45 or 20 49.
caroline thanks very much indeed
thank you
well with me now is our climate
correspondent hannah thomas peter so
hannah how significant is a resignation
like this it's very unusual i think to
hear from somebody so closely and so
recently involved with a major oil and
gas company of course it's come at a
time when the oil and gas industry is
under in intense scrutiny and facing
severe criticism not just for their
ongoing role in climate change you know
the un has said that fossil fuel needs
to stay in the ground there can't be any
new extraction but also
for enjoying record profits driven by
the energy crisis and the war in ukraine
which has prompted calls for a windfall
tax among other things
but the broader context remains this
that
this government the uk's government
believes that
oil and gas in particular are going to
be necessary in the coming decades you
simply cannot turn the tax off and you
can't turn the taps off even quickly
and that gas is a necessary transition
fuel as we push towards a net zero
future and that critically gas can be
extracted and those net zero targets
remain
you know intact so there is a
disagreement between people like ms
dennett and campaigners who say that
oil and gas companies are going to be
responsible in large part for the world
missing its global heating targets
and those who are you know right at the
face of this including the british
government trying to make policy around
this who say that the two things can be
achieved that we can continue to extract
oil and gas to an extent and we can
still continue to eventually reduce our
carbon emissions to zero by 2050. hannah
thanks very much indeed
and that's it for today thanks very much
for watching